hey I'm Mark Consuelos hey I'm Mark
Consuelos I'm Mark Consuelos and I am
and we are taking that did this happen
on Riverdale or did I just make it up
quiz husband Archie got mauled by a bear
while on the run after breaking out of
prison
Cheryl waterboarded her mother Penelope
with maple syrup that happens yes yes
jelly beans Jones is actually a 32 year
old member of the farm who has been
posing as Jughead sister that's gotta be
real Betty Cooper tested positive for
the see the serial killer gene for sure
really yeah
do you read the scripts pop Tate was
smuggling jingle-jingle to the sisters
of quiet mercy through french fries that
would be brilliant
that would be all it may become real
nothing pop kate is like sacrilege if
you can't you can't make him better
Jason blossom never really died he was
just posing as just as the gang was
about to take the SATs the proctor died
from cyanide poisoning go rogue fail the
quiz a bunch of nuns poison themselves
to avoid testifying against Hyrule ah
damn right they did and nuns we're gonna
testify against me do you read the
script it's real really okay I ever ran
away to NYC with his mistress and
launched a talk show called live with
iram and bullring
there's a character named peaches and
cream oh yeah
Mary Andrews is actually a blossom
probably going to be true one day its
face man arose runs an underground civil
defense training center for at-risk
youth and baby teeth died maybe to thin
down found them Betty chloroformed Alice
that's truly she did yeah yeah was it a
reverse okay yep right there it did it
automatically yeah I got more right I
think I got 14 you got cheated on Buzz
thanks so much for watching this was the
Riverdale plot or not on BuzzFeed watch
Riverdale
[Music]